we just had a fun meeting
yeah we had a fun meet and i don't know
if we should talk about this
should we she text your lawyer first we
had a fun meeting with the people that
run the sub stack
so have you heard of this now
subs that journalists
can't get things published in the
mainstream news
um
when they're writing because the
mainstream news we all know
is corporate sponsored
propaganda
and
these people are fearless thought
leaders
yeah
yeah
yes they are
yes they are so
they're fearless thought leaders
and
which i like i'm all for substance go
make that money hey go make that bread
barry
who came to the show he had a great show
at the comedy store kevin hart chris
rock uh
and then barry weiss came to the show
and did i did 30 minutes uh talked about
uh uh israel
at the end we appreciated that
uh we had a meeting with the sub stack
founder wanted to meet with me
and i brought you yes
it's much like in good will hunting
when matt damon just sent ben affleck
when he didn't want it yeah i went in
there like ben affleck like
retainer well they they called me and
ben right yes yes and it described for
the people what they're trying to do
because the show on patreon is big
and they want us to jump they want us to
jump over from patreon to them and take
everything with with us and get off and
get off youtube yes for free for free
and get off youtube as well for no money
cause you're friends because we believe
in what they're doing
so they call us a woman called this and
she's a nice woman she's a peppy
she's a pep
and she called hi
hi
we're like big fans
i
i'm like 20 million bucks
20 million dollars i mean you saw her
dress she could afford it 20 no she
can't
20 million dollars
like i said if you give me 20 million
i'll youtube i'll say youtube i'm off
sorry susan which whatever name is i
leave here and then i leave the patreon
i don't know who the hell runs at
20 million but because we got businesses
that make money
rogan got a lot but you got to pay money
here
and so then we threw that number out and
then she you could tell she was like
aghast at that number on the phone she
didn't understand it maybe she thought
you were joking that's why they went
through at the meeting yeah so i don't
know what she thought but then she said
we want you should sit down
with the founder of
sub stack
because they want to be doing more stuff
with content so i brought you you
brought me yeah
you brought me in it was a message you
were basically saying me and my friend
were walking and we may walk by that
restaurant we're having fun you're not
in la all the time no
this is not a serious signing meeting i
can tell that yeah the message is uh i'm
gonna fit you into what i'm doing yeah
yeah we're gonna and and and how do you
think it went did you enjoy it it was a
as we said it was a good show
it was fun it was a good show you
you
set the game at the beginning yeah they
they thought hey we're gonna sit down
they were thinking like this is gonna be
a three-hour meal we're gonna get to
know tim and only tim yeah the
reservation was for four right we had to
change tables they were like oh who's
this yeah and tim's like this is my
friend we had to find a new table they
had to put us in another section of the
restaurant yeah and they thought it was
just gonna be a nice bonding
dinner
where
you were
an ally in the revolution right yeah
they didn't know that you were there to
let them know we're playing a different
game and that game is
listen let's get right to it
because let's not act like we all don't
have real friends yeah i mean let's say
that let's get back to our real friends
we we have real friends they said let's
we all have real friends yeah and you
know we're like
let's not get right to it yes cut it out
yeah yeah let's cut it out here we all
got real friends waiting for us are you
smoking crack
uh we're not moving the operation
to sub stack
for no money
[Music]
are you on
crack cocaine
sir
good sir and madam
they said to me they go we'd love if you
did it for a reason it was other than
financial
what
no
i well i'm not gonna do it
the only reason i would do it if you
gave me a shitload of money and i don't
have to charge anybody any more money on
patreon meaning like
my fans get the same deal they've always
had they don't get [ __ ] over at all
and you give me a chunk of money
then maybe we'll consider it
but you didn't want to just
the thing that i was a little
surprised by was that you didn't want to
get to know them better they they seemed
like it would be a fun hank yeah they
wanted yeah they wanted to like be
buddies
they thought we were going to be buds
and they thought it was going to work
out where i would be like hey you know
it would be fun
i was going to call ben and go let's
just just just delete the patreon right
now
they thought i was gonna do in the
middle of dinner i go hey why don't we
delete let's just delete the uh youtube
and the patreon yeah i you know you guys
are visionaries and i just want to do it
for the culture the cause yeah i'm
excited i'm excited about it and
that's why i worked so hard to build it
on my own just so i could
just over dinner i could be charmed and
give it away yeah and they go they go we
don't want to own you yeah
i go
well i'm not owned now right nobody owns
me now
they're like well what's great about the
sub stack is we have the email
yeah
they go we have the email list have you
you have we have email on the site we
can email the people they know we have
that too right i don't know if they do
know that we have email they go we have
email you can email your people when
their episodes come out you send the
email they were really searching for
reasons why they didn't know they didn't
know they had no idea they had no idea
what the advantage would be they go well
it's a community yeah
it's a community of people that get
emails yeah
don't you want and i said i like what
you're doing i like the idea that these
journalists can go make money
andrew sullivan and barry weiss and uh
greenwald and taibu whoever these are
people that should have a platform and a
way to monetize uh their stuff but then
they were like [ __ ] on patreon it's
like listen
you're just doing what patreon did
for journalists that's exactly what it
is that's what it is yeah you're
cheating on the thing that you that
that's the whole thing right right it
would almost be like if patreon met with
the journalists right and said hey guys
why don't you come over here for nothing
and then you'll be like wouldn't that
disrupt my whole thing right and they go
no no no no no no no because we have
email yeah what about the email
situation have you heard of the email
we can send emails to people here you
don't have to go to the post office
anymore yeah it's not snail mail we got
real email we got the real thing we got
real email here yeah and uh they were
nice enough people but they didn't i
don't i don't think they fully
understood
what
they were saying
no yeah like i said they were calling
for a different type of meeting the
meeting they had was a lot shorter than
they expected was i rude no i don't
think you were rude i was cold
i think i think you were realistic i
think it was well the restaurant's
disgusting yeah well that part brought
me to a dump then you admitted you'd
never been there before why would you
take me someplace you've never been
these tech people don't eat they don't
know anything about food right um
and they brought me to some dump right
and and then it was just kind of a
contentious back and forth and then well
i stood up and left yeah right in the
middle of one of their sentences yeah
yeah you went oh i forgot i have to do
this thing and that was it and they were
like yeah
one of the guys his face was just turned
red a lot right it looked like he was it
looked like he was on a date with a
crush and he just kept turning red
from
his
expectation that things would have been
different and they were not what he
thought well it it's kind of wild to me
to imagine that somebody would disrupt
their entire thing to go over to this
other thing that has value i'm sure i
mean people make money there
for nothing
for nothing
yeah
what are we talking about yeah that's
that's exactly how elon musk got started
i want all of the money you're giving to
katie herzog i want it now
that's exactly how all the big guys got
started they built the thing and then
someone came and said do it over here
just do it here make us big it's
the guy goes i'd like you to be jazzed
about it
are you jazzed
i go no you're you're not saying there's
no money yeah
yeah and then one guy goes well why is
it so much money i go will you give me
three times what i'm making minimum yeah
because why change anything it's not
broke don't fix who cares right now if
the guy wasn't foreign from a country
that you
australia i got problems with them and
why
i said during the quarantine lockdown
that australians were lazy criminals who
wanted to drink in their backyards and
didn't value having any kind of rights
including the right to work which in
australia is laughable it's like america
the right to exercise right right you
know australia the right to work it's
like nobody
i mean it's just it's not even real
there okay there's a few people in
australia that work very few
um but the vast majority of people who
live in australia are wombats
there's nothing wrong with that but
they're you know what i mean yeah
they're like doing chewies they're
drinking beer out of their shoe
they're animals
are we you know and i get death threats
all the time about this and then they
want me to go toward there to get killed
really australians get really that bent
out of shape some of them get mad they
can't take a joke yeah and the other
problem is i'm not
joking that's the problem right but this
guy was fun enough the australian guy he
was trying he was trying he was trying
yeah he was really trying he was trying
he reminded
me of like a girl who's been kidnapped
yeah
and
she's seen the face of the guy that's
kidnapped her and she's pleading just
please i want to see my parents please
let let me live and the guy goes of
course i'm gonna let you live if you're
just good and do what i say right and
then
in the back of her head she has a little
hope and she keeps you know and then she
knows she when she turns around he's
just gonna hit her in the head with a
brick yeah to kill the witness
yeah the vibe was like a little glimmer
of hope even just out of desperation
you said substance they're having
problems right now what's going on with
they got the q on people in there now
yeah i'll pull this up they've david
i saw that on right wing watch today ugh
don't bring up right wing watch i hate
them
i hate anyone that's watching anyone
stop watching
left wing any of the watches
why anti-vaxxers q anon influencers and
white nationalists are flocking to sub
stack
well this is going to be silly
let's i mean
what are they mad about here robert
malone and baron said let him say what
they want to say
who are the queen on influencers i'm
more interested in that i'm bored of
this vaccine nonsense you got to admit
the q and guys got better imaginations
if you're still in q anon right now it's
nothing short of downright impressive it
is it is commitment the fact that you've
been queuing on is like guys at the in
2009 during the mortgage crisis they're
like no it's still good
it's still good yeah
my favorite was when they were showing
up in dallas
at daily plaza
waiting for jfk junior to come back i
mean that is beauty they're having more
fun on earth than we will ever have
um
you got to admit it's fun it's a fun
club it's it's absolutely fun it's a lot
more fun than the other side who's just
going around you got to be in a club
yeah so whether you get an ape nft and
change your profile picture and then
you're in the that board 8 got club yeah
or you go to d lee plaza and wait for
jfk junior to come back the latter
sounds a lot funnier to me some guy
mercola is open about the fact that he's
using substance to publish content which
even he himself considered to be too
controversial to keep on his own website
in may 2021 he deleted posts on a site
which promoted a range of false cover 19
cures including effectively inhaling
bleach
i kind of liked that in his substance
post mercola announcing he'd be bringing
his deleted content back by publishing
it on the platform
that is kind of funny hey all that
content i got rid of it's back baby i
love that his cure is the same as an
alcohol desperate alcoholic who's ran
out of real bottles right just just
start huffing
just start looking that's what
alcoholics do when they're out they just
start looking under the sink but here's
the deal
people this is a subscriber model you
subscribe
what's the problem adults subscribing
for the entertainment they want this
isn't a super bowl commercial no
we're not going in the middle of super
bowl saying in hale bleach yeah covered
hey right wing watch if you haven't
noticed this is a private club it's a
private club people pay to get in why
you can't it's just like any private
club right you're on someone's property
right now how about you go after the
bohemian grove for like skull and balt
like what about those they're private
clubs yes
q and on influencers uh
are on sub stack
jordan sather patel patriot and
technofrog
techno fog technology technofog post
regularly for both free and paid
subscribers
while in the comments q and followers
engage with one another to debate and
share conspiracy well where would you
where do you want them to do it right
where do you want them to do it
that could have been an effective pitch
if they did it much better if they said
hey tim yes you know
you joke about everybody yes you're a
comedian
but if you ever wan lose it right if you
ever lose it right and go hard right we
got your back no it would be better if
they sat me down and said there's it's a
matter of time before you degenerate
it's a matter of time before you turn
that corner right we want to let you
know we are that core it's a safe place
for you we are will allow you to go rant
and rave about whatever you think
the problem is that week yeah
whatever scrambled brain
you have
in the future it has a home it has a
home it's just on sub
yes that at least would have been a
pitch it would have been something it
would have been smart yeah
i don't even want to go into all the
names of the people i don't care they've
named a ton of people
it doesn't matter to me because i i i
don't if you're subscribing
who gives a [ __ ] right but
isn't it a hip place for a comedian to
be in a club with a bunch of classical
liberal journalists
that's the other thing i mean that's as
hip as it gets there's no comedians over
there no and if they want a comedian to
come over there they gotta
you know
give me a lot of money money
that's all we're talking about yeah
that's the difference between comedians
and journalists comedians have the
potential and often do make real money
right yeah what i should have said is
yes i'll do it for free yes but my show
is me and alex jones
let me tell you who my show is before
i'm gonna do it for free they would have
smiled and been excited i would have
said
you got me yeah i hey yeah you're right
yeah i don't need any money to delete
the youtube channel in the patreon can
you imagine these psychopaths we'll
delete it all and we'll build it back
from scratch so it's me and alex jones
you go there you go we want the tim
dylan joe you go you know what i don't
want to do the tim dojo tim dillon
show's dead i want to do crisis actors
tim dillon and alex jones i have a new
show called sandy hook question mark
where me and alex jones go over the
evidence because there's evidence
there's not but i would say that at the
dinner because there's evidence no i've
seen some auditions in backstage
magazine for crisis yes i've seen it
yeah i've seen it people that want to
pretend they got shot yeah yeah outside
of a school yeah but it didn't work and
we laughed and unfortunately i think the
door is now going to be shut
after this show that's so strange
because at the end you said let's keep
talking
let's keep talking yeah i'm talking now
yes i think that's what you meant yeah
we're all talking you're like i'll be
talking later
yeah yeah we're gonna talk yeah
it was fun
one of them said
he thinks he could come up with
something that you might be interested
in i remember that yeah yeah what a
commemorative mug
they added in mines
a tote bag
bag what would the point be this is the
thing
now people are probably listening to
this going you greedy pig all you want
is money yeah okay that's number one
what else would be the point yeah what's
the point friendship right
[Laughter]
they go no you have all your content in
one place yeah you've got it in youtube
and on patreon and oh it's all over they
were basically saying like don't you
want to hide it all yeah you know how
everything's decentralized what if you
centralize it all yeah you know how it's
so accessible on every platform yeah
what if we hit it on ours what if we
hide it and put it somewhere yeah
yeah that's basically this new thing
which i didn't realize every subscriber
that signed up would have to be
interviewed by barry weiss
whether they were anti-semitic or not
they threw that in at the end there's a
test barry weiss gives every new
subscriber she calls you on the phone
and and goes through 10 questions if
you're anti-semitic